Now in her 17th term in Congress, House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi has been front and center all
year working to advance the Biden administration’s
agenda, and her poll numbers show the scars.
The formidable Speaker, like her Republican
predecessor Paul Ryan, is regarded more unfavorably
than favorably today.
A November 2021 Wall Street Journal poll of
registered voters put her rating at 36 percent
favorable and 57 percent unfavorable.
Gallup has tracked Pelosi’s ratings since
2003, when she became House Minority Leader.
Since 2008, her unfavorable ratings have always
exceeded her favorable ones.
She’s not alone.
Most congressional leaders are more unpopular
than popular.
In Gallup’s latest question, for example,
her Republican counterpart in the Senate,
Mitch McConnell was more unfavorably regarded
than Pelosi.
Pelosi’s ability to navigate the different
factions in her party is well known.
But she may not be able to survive losing
the House: The most recent CNBC All-American
survey found the largest GOP advantage ever
(10 points) on the question that asks which
party Americans would prefer to control Congress
in the next election.